all right so let's get started a welcome
back everyone clearly I'm not Krista and
Krista should really give that
presentation because it was her who gave
the quantum computing class ed you dub
earlier this year in in winter term 2019
which was when we went out publicly and
we taught a new group of students kind
of the future workforce for quantum
computing taught them quantum algorithms
taught them how to use Q sharp to
actually express quantum algorithms and
I want to give you an overview of that
class it includes the kind of contents I
will also show you a little bit buddy
the technical parts were also the
feedback that we heard from the students
and kind of feel free to interrupt me at
any time to ask questions I will be
probably helpful to get this dialogue
going a little bit just for a little bit
of context so you heard in the mornin
already about quantum computing what it
is what the potential is and maybe also
what potential applications are but
let's take a step back like a long time
ago we had classical computers that
looked kind of like this this is an
ENIAC a knife from 1946 it was located
in Pennsylvania
I think Germany had similar machines
Conrad Sousa built them in Germany those
machines were designed to solve the
hardest problems of the day back then in
the in the 40s they were typically
related to some form of cryptography or
computing ballistics maybe and people
probably kind of could feel that there
is more that's just a tip of an iceberg
there could be more but they used the
machines already for good purpose they
did use them to tackle the hardest
problems and we're kind of at a similar
juncture in quantum computing we have
these little devices small devices that
are emerging we have that we can sense
that these things will be useful we know
it once they get very large they can do
amazing things things that are beyond
the tractable what's what's classically
tractable but it's really a long road
that we still have ahead of us to
understand better what we can do with
the machines so it's time to develop
that future to really think what
can be mapped to the machine and so far
the quantum field has grown it has grown
exponentially from very very few people
in the mid 90s I remembered there were
seminars back then they had maybe 10 15
people - now a much larger community but
still there's another phase transition
that what needs to happen to go to a
really broad workforce in quantum
computing so they you draw in a lot of
people a lot of new ideas and then maybe
you have that one-in-a-million event
that you find a new algorithm that will
be a breakthrough so when we are trying
to think about that that these events
that might happen we need to kind of
also think about training the engineers
of the future so that he or she actually
is enabled to come up with these new
algorithms and of course we also need to
find the algorithms themselves and that
there's kind of this these these loops
where you have an idea and you try to
verify or falsify it does it even make
sense right you might have an idea and
then you initially don't know does that
pan out there were so many attempts and
that typically in research that's how it
works right you try something it doesn't
work and go back to the drawing where
you try again and as researchers we've
been through that a lot and it's really
useful to have tools that help you in
that process and that try something
falsify the idea go back and kind of
that's also one of the motivations here
to provide these tools to help our
future generations of quantum
researchers and developers in that
process and just to try out ideas right
ideally we try to like to try them out
on hardware hardware is growing at a at
a certain speed sometimes software is a
little bit ahead you can do stuff with
simulators or with emulators that you
can do already today that you might have
to wait a few more years until it's
actually coming into fruition on
hardware and of course ideally would
like to co-opt ax Mize for the entire
system stack we'd like to optimize for
the classical computers needed for a
quantum computer part and those are all
complex things it's important to educate
people about it and just a little thing
about the applications themselves right
so how does it typical
exploration of that space work the
typically a starting point is you have a
quantum algorithm where you have a
certain idea and for that you need
algorithms designers they need to find
an algorithm that hit that a principal
officer speed-up but then you need to
confirm that speed-up because it's one
thing to have speed-up in this in the
asymptotic sense if your scale to large
sizes now at some point you will have a
speed-up it's important to understand
the actual cross over point over the
best previous method and for that you
need to have you need to get a sense of
the constants that might be involved in
the asymptotic scaling right so yet kind
of you need to implement first of all
all the operations at Sur against a
certain gate set including the IO and
some methods for instance in quantum
machine learning there's often a hidden
cost that sometimes people make neglect
that has to do with the with the input
of the how do you actually represent
your problem so you need to really spell
it all out and then optimize the code as
much as you can and then maybe even
target the hardware to get really
footprint analyses at the lowest level
once you have done that then you got a
really good sense if that algorithm can
actually be run one day so that those
are complex things and the future work
force hopefully will have a lot of
people who can help us with all these
stages right right now we have already a
few people where we good if we had a
whole workforce that could help with
that any questions so far
just point okay now I'm gonna switch
gears and go into the the course that
was taught earlier this year as I
mentioned so the motivation for this was
well we need an educated workforce we
need to find developers software
engineers algorithms engineers these are
very diverse requirements that the mix
of we have software engineers but also
maybe more mathematical skills also
physics skills they need to all come
together in this new field of quantum
information processing and well it was
an undergrad course that was the
requirement so and that's a great
opportunity to ignite the passion in the
young audience they're eager to learn
of course the flip side there might be
not a lot of deep knowledge yet
available in that in that undergrad
class the the folks there they may be
heard a little bit about linear algebra
but now they get exposed to this kind of
very complex topic so we had to get
ahead around how to actually present it
and in that in doing so we develop
materials to actually enable learning
and to enable it enable learning quantum
computing via programming a programmatic
approach so just this was a computer
science class that's a great match with
Q sharp which is a programming language
and kind of the development of the
course materials went hand in hand with
creating programming exercises materials
that that help you understand quantum
computing from a very programmatic and
very hands-on point of view and I'm
gonna get into that in a moment just a
little bit about the course itself it
was hosted this winner started in
January it targeted third and fourth
year undergrads I think most were in
third year a prereqs were linear algebra
and programming and ideally people would
have had a notion of what a proof is and
good understanding of algorithms it was
a full credit course and we at the end
had a steady state of about 35 students
it was a very tough course I should say
that right away so there were some
people who felt that they could not keep
up with a pace and it was quite
challenging but we had a steady state
and at the end I think those were kind
of really happy and they they met the
challenge I'm gonna have a few word
clouds at the end that show what they
what their thinking was I mean thinking
of this this class there was three
lecture hours per week Tuesdays and
Thursdays in the afternoon we had
several guest speakers in the class but
Christa did the brunt of the the
lectures and she did office hours with
the students the whole thing ran for ten
weeks
there was no lab section per se but
there were a lot of programming
assignments where the students had this
homework and then they did the the the
grading by the TAS
support in form of automatic testers and
that's you heard about that in the
morning from Maria that's actually one
of the really salient features of
teaching it with a programming a support
is that you can have these these very
helpful programmatic things that help
you grade automatically and so you can
test this doesn't actually run it's
literally a unit test that you write in
a programming language that performs the
test and you can check that the students
pass it or not yes yeah okay so is this
apologize if this okay I'm not quite
sure I would have to get back to you on
that question is it's the question
whether you get extra credits for taking
program oh I see okay it's quite
possible I don't know the answer to be
quite honest I can look it up for you
and get back to you be happy to get back
all right cool that's a good question I
think it was a quite diverse class I
don't know the exact ratio but I think
it was it was not only like catering
definitely not catering to the male and
male audience and I think it was a
relatively good balance but of course as
we know in stem there is there's a need
to balance it more and I think I think I
mean I can speak to the fact that we
hired a few summer interns from that
class who did exceptionally well in the
class and completed not only the
programming exercise but also competed
in competitions and we have a very
balanced gender ratio among those
recruits from the internship program
that of course doesn't mean that the
class itself was I gave two lectures I
thought they it was a high ratio but I
don't know the exact numbers for that I
would refer to two to Krista to get back
to you yeah cool yeah any more questions
cool there are great great questions
already thank you
yeah the challenges were that most of
the curricula today that you find where
people I mean corn computing has been
around for a while many quantum
computing courses have been taught many
of them focus on the graduate level so
that's already hot you have a higher
entry point people know maybe more
linear algebra no have deeper
programming skills and only few existing
courses actually have a hands-on
component where you go through the
curriculum and you have programming
exercises for each for each a new
concept that you learn in the class and
this is a biggie and not all students
have taken physics I think pretty much
none of the students have taken physics
it so it kind of we had to cast and all
these notions that you kind of need to
know in a way that they are not
intimidating that student feeling that
so that the students feel included that
they it's at the pace of their of them
as they learn the new concepts and a lot
of stuff has also to do with like things
that we even don't even think about much
like notation that can be actually
setting a higher barrier right if you
have a lot of fancy notations that we
are used to as quantum computing
researchers that might be a real put off
for a new person trying to learn the
field so we we try to make conscious
choices and intentional choices what to
put in there in in actually the
materials sometimes I think it was still
overwhelming overwhelming but if you
lots of he was that wouldn't be nice if
we did not have to know quantum
mechanics and I think that's very much
true you can learn quantum computing
without knowing without having had a
quantum mechanics class before I think
it's fair to say if you don't know
linear algebra it's it's pretty it's
very very difficult to learn
quantum computing so you must have a
notion of linear operators like vector
spaces that is a must otherwise you you
cannot catch up with a piece of a class
and then the other philosophy was to
teach quantum algorithms through
programming but it really goes both ways
if you want to really do hands-on
quantum programming of algorithms or
cars or homework you have to have a
sense of what the algorithm does so it
goes both ways
and I'm glad with Maria pointed that out
to me earlier because that's actually a
really key point when you actually eat
if you're deep in the craving and you
want to help the students with the
programming it's pretty obvious that we
have to spend a lot of time explaining
the basics very well like what the gates
are what does the concept what happens
if you apply it if you apply an operator
to the zero state what do you get but it
goes on from there like people struggle
with stuff like what's the encoding is
it gonna be little-endian or big-endian
encoding if I write down a number in
binary right do I read it essentially
from the left or to the right those
things matter a lot when you code it and
in the books maybe it's sometimes not
even mentioned explicitly what the
encoding is right so those those things
are important so when you want to code
it first you need to understand the
algorithm well then you need to
understand how I represent the data and
then you can actually get going we
taught it in in-person lectures so this
was not an online course people actually
went to u-dub and deliver the lectures
and we taught it through coding
assignments
besides the lectures and and did the
written homework so there were these
three elements there was in-person
classes written homeworks and those were
kind of alternating with programming
homeworks okay yeah we try to strip as
much of the physics out as possible you
can't do it completely but we presented
qubits as vectors operators as matrices
as much as possible we try to not
overwhelm people with bra ket notation
too much even though of course the
experts in the field do that we try to
use it as much as possible just plain
vectors and we avoided that that's
actually something as a researcher
maybe you get your cringe but we try to
avoid proofs as much as possible only to
the extent where it made sense because
that's again a barrier that we might set
for people I think we had a couple of
proofs for really things that are
insightful and where you learn something
we focused also more on the computer
science topics in quantum computing you
have this kind of it comes a lot from
physics and it's about a simulation of
physical systems so you can also of
course approach it from that angle and
teach it a lot about like a lot about
the fundamental physics that you're now
able to simulate we tried to
de-emphasize that a little bit and
emphasize more the computer science
topics I cool yeah as I mentioned this
already there was written homework and
programming homework and there was a
final project so that that actually had
a big weight in the class there were no
final there was no final exam there was
no midterm exam so that the grade was
composed of these three components and
this was the students had actually a
opportunity to earn some extra bonus
points by competing in a coding
competition that was run at towards the
end of the the course that's a very cool
thing I personally super passionate
about these things Maria is the
mastermind of this she designs coding
competitions and it's a highly
non-trivial thing to do you have to kind
of have a completely automatic framework
that runs in sandboxes so that the
participants sands ascend solutions to
this platform it gets automatically it
like it spawns up a sandbox runs the
code inside checks whether it's correct
and then basically you earn whether you
pass that exercise or not so we use the
platform called code forces and ran that
conduct competition on it and the
problems in this competition is the
second one we did based on Q sharp the
problems were ranging from relatively
easy to really tough so in this
competition because the first one was
passed by so many people we wanted to
put a few nuggets in there that are
really tough and at the end of the day
we had over 20 I think or do you
remember how many
all the exercises or the 25 and the
overall participation worldwide okay
200 people competed in it you know you
typically have like a higher
registration first but in a little bit
less actually compete but it's a really
that's a sizable participation and over
20 people completed all several of those
actually hired for India for internships
but yeah that's that's a great indicator
that the people are involved they use
the language they are able to tackle
complex problems with it cool let's
shift gears let's I wanted to walk you
through some some of the content just to
give you a better idea for instance we
had a lecture on the free transform
which is really bread-and-butter of
quantum computing oops just doesn't work
too well for some reason
okay
you have to manually step through here
so those are basic quantum algorithms
that you learn about in the textbooks
this is so-called dojo saw algorithm and
then we used that algorithm to teach a
more advanced concept namely that off to
the free transform so got these spectral
analyses are very important in quantum
computing and a lot of that has to do
with the fact that the quantum Fourier
transform it can be done extremely fast
so on a quantum computer it you have
even a faster version of the classical
FFT you have a super fast Fourier
transform and we try to kind of lead and
build up towards that that notion and
what you didn't actually can do with
these fast Fourier transforms so your
intuitively go from n log n as a
complexity turn of an algorithm to just
log N or log square locks lock square N
and then we want to give students a feel
for that and explain why that's so
powerful so we build up by some well
mathematical things first but in week we
we kind of showed them spectra of
functions and try to teach them what's
special about certain classes of
functions what can you learn from the
spectrum and then we we found that that
one of the quantum algorithms pioneers
actually works for Microsoft he retired
last year but we were able to meet him
dan Simon and we there's one programming
exercise that's actually based on his
algorithm and that's actually one of the
things student learn about in that class
as well but it's a very common algorithm
that leads you up to Shor's algorithm
which is an even more prominent quantum
algorithm for factoring and then the
Fourier transform we tried to kind of
mix up very visual elements students get
a better feel for what happens for
instance if you run Shor's algorithm at
some point you will see very sharp peaks
over some basis states and that's really
where the information is that's what you
can extract by using a quantum computer
and that can in turn be used for
factoring so we try to highlight these
connections to classical signal
processing also and then there was
another lecture I wanted to highlight
[Music]
another famous algorithm is the
so-called Grover algorithm which helps
to search for elements that meet a
specific specifications I'll think of it
you have a predicate and now you want to
find an input to that predicate that
meets the condition so it's kind of
search really right think for instance
of a three set formula you try to find a
satisfying assignment and this Grover
algorithm helps you to speed up the
process classically if you cannot say
anything about the predicate then pretty
much there's nothing better that you can
do than brute forcing it going through
all the vectors if it's literally a
black box but quantumly you can get a
square root speed-up for this problem
and this just Grover algorithm does that
what's nice about the algorithm is so
I'm just sipping through the slides here
apologies I just wanted to show you that
conceptually it's a quite simple
algorithm and you can you can understand
it once you know the basic notions such
as unitary operators measurement and
what complex phases are you can actually
understand this this problem and this
algorithm quite well I wanted to just
show you the circuit I think it's a long
time till I get there yeah so here that
the point is that you do only a squirrel
number of queries to your predicate so
you want to find a satisfying assignment
to the predicate and you do a squared
number of n and it's the total number of
candidates to this and I think the
students grasp this algorithm
particularly well so for some reason
that problem of finding kind of this
constraint satisfaction problem of
finding solutions really resonated with
them and they gave us feedback that they
really liked that algorithm it was one
of the things they liked most in this
entire class and okay we just wanted to
show you the algorithm itself that by
the way was also explored in the code so
there was
there was exercises to code up the
predicate so the quantum computing is
often called the Oracles and then okay
this is the algorithm itself as you can
see it's quite simple in its structure
it just alternates two operators and you
can understand both it kind of you can
drill down what is inside that box and
it's a very nice algorithm once you
understand the basic principle so that's
something you can teach quite quickly
actually without a lot of math baggage
that you might need otherwise that's all
there's number theory you need to learn
to understand Shor's algorithm and so on
a quick look at the syllabus itself so
we had topics ranging from an
introduction then a quick introduction
to Q sharp yeah an overview of what what
Shor's algorithm is the fourier
transform was a big component to that
groves are girls not just mentioned
there's also Hamiltonian simulation
which relates much more to the physics
and we also had a really cool segment
about error correcting codes which is
essential to build kuan computers it
it's a lot related to classical error
correction classical codes which
students typically did not experience so
far in there at that stage in their in
their education but I think that was a
very smooth and gentle introduction to
the topic and then it's kind of clear
how to go from there what's the next
step if you want to learn more and we
proceeded along like the theory part
proceeded along very well-established
resources so that is in our field is
very popular resources such as John
Prescott's
lecture notes is a professor at Caltech
and wrote a really good it's essentially
a book but it's available for free then
there is a book by Keith high-fat I'll a
book by John abide by Scott Aaronson
poop by John Waters and other students
use the kind of Nilsen and chong which
is one of the very common
textbooks in quantum computing back to
the to the presentation here if I am
able to go back yeah we serve it
afterwards yes there was a survey we I
don't know if he surveyed pre what would
the survey pre consist of expectation
I'm not a hundred percent sure but I
would assume it was we did not pre
survey them
I mean it was probably like in in the
kind of office hours probably we learned
about what expectations were but I don't
think they did a formal pre-survey but I
came back come back can get back to you
regarding that as well they did
definitely did a post survey um I have a
problem here right now okay here we go
so um yes so here's a quick quick
summary of the final project students
gave were allowed to to team up and work
with peers on the projects then finally
they gave ten minute presentations on
the findings and they wrote code all of
the class projects had to do with code
in that sense they were really carefully
selected because you cannot just make up
any problem and say now now solve that
and write code so there were there were
for instance problems in arithmetic to
implement addition circuits but to give
a new twist on it so it was something
that hasn't been done before to do it in
very low depth so they're additions
addition circuits that you can do in
logarithmic depth essentially so the
students got the teeth sanctities into
it and actually implemented this
actually quite cool and there were other
projects on free transform itself to
implement that was very nice and yeah
some simple games there foundations of
quantum mechanics that that play in
there and that there was actually also
nice to see that happening yeah
regarding a read out I'm not gonna give
give a lot of detail but kind of the
word cloud looked like this a lot of
people thought it was
interesting people felt there was a lot
of math in there but people also found
it to be difficult and challenging some
people found it to be even stressful or
time-consuming but also exciting and fun
so there was a breadth and kind of we
will take those feedback that feedback
too hard and especially the feedback
that it was difficult and the pace was
high so that's actually I have ever side
a little bit later that that about what
we could do regarding that we asked also
about things that they particularly
liked what of the content they
particularly liked so Grover actually
scored very very hard it's not even
reflected by the font here the font
should be maybe three times the point
size it's just that the tool that we
used to generate this didn't handle this
Grover was extremely popular QFT was
popular Shor's algorithm was popular but
also topics such as teleportation which
are you don't have that in classical
computer science at all right it's a new
concept people like that and also like
the basic the prince the basic things
they really liked or defining liked it
error correction yeah any questions
about that yeah here's a here's some
verbatim feedback people liked the fact
that it was stimulating they thought it
was amazing to learn about this new area
and it they were happy that it took it
on the more critical side yeah it
stretched the thinking some for some
that meant also that it was too much in
a short amount of time material was
difficult they struggled and yeah
they're just a workload and kind of to
balance that out a little bit more there
was a feedback we got yeah so here the
learning so this this is now towards the
end of the course and by the way if
you're interested in getting access to
the materials the stuff I just showed
the the lecture the slides the written
assignments and so on and we can
definitely help you with that we'd love
to actually engage with you and for that
please contact mark sangwoo's
the audience is sitting in the back row
shoot him an email and we can work with
you and we'll be actually wonderful to
see more and different curricula
building on this would be fantastic we'd
love to work with you so yeah what's the
learning so some of the homework
assignments were too advanced both on
the written part and the programming
part for sure so we assumed more
mathematics than the students actually
had so we had actually no data points
really about the students maybe we
should have done these pre surveys that
were mentioned next time we probably
should choose a if it teaches again or
if others teach that course again we
should probably choose a problem subset
of the problem set and narrow it a
little bit down how many problems we do
the competition as a homework assignment
initially the coding competition that I
mentioned was an assignment and then we
converted it into a bonus problem that
was too stressful because there were
several contributing factors but one is
like competing in such a public
competition where it's really
competitive coding you get the problem
and you have to solve it in a short
amount of time that's what it's about
that is really stressful and not
everybody is up for that challenge
initially I think eventually it's a
really cool thing to do but it's not for
everyone and so we will will we decided
not to make that a required like
assignment next time maybe make it
optional extra credit from the get-go
and then what we learned also is that
yeah you need to have a really you need
to have more domain knowledge really to
get to get deeper and some trigonometry
for instance
complex numbers obviously number theory
chemistry because as soon as you want to
dive a little bit deeper you need to
know all these things and if you have to
teach them from scratch it takes just a
long time it's important to state also
the state-of-the-art classical
approaches for all these problems which
also eats into the time budget for the
class right so you want to say what's
the best known algorithm previously just
to establish the context
for instance for factoring you maybe
want to say what is typically the the
complexity not that you could really
drill into these algorithms they are
very complex themselves but at least
establishing that context and it takes a
while and then just for an undergrad
audience probably it's better to remove
some of those algorithms we covered a
really broad spectrum but to focus on
fewer would probably be better all right
and then it brings me to the end of the
presentation thank you very much for
your attention
[Applause]
more questions it's a great question
would it have been better to make
physics a prereq I think I think that
might have made the transition in I'm
kind of entering the class and entering
the flow of the lectures easier but then
you lose a lot of people right from like
the subscription you have a much narrow
pool of people to work with yeah you
could have done it but if you make
physics those were all computer science
undergrads you if you make physics or
requirements then you probably have
would have narrowed it way below 50 but
it's it's a good question especially
when you talk about grad courses then
you might have made that you might make
that requirement but that that was not
major requirement for this class
questions okay so first is um did you do
any like in-class active learning stuff
and if so what did you do like make them
design circuits with their neighbor or
something oh I see on the spot during
the class I don't think that happened a
lot in the in that sense that they
partnered up with people around them in
the class but what definitely happened
is we went through the solutions of
programming exercises in front of the
class and did it in a live way so that
one of the lectures for instance I gave
I started out by doing kind of showing
last week's programming assignment and
what was really cool about that was I
basically
up a lot they and then I people saw what
I did wrong they could help me fix it on
the spot
and then I was able to pass all the unit
tests by writing the correct program so
often times it was just correct III
called it correctly but then you're in
front of the audience
you just make mistakes and then people I
balled it and I think there was learning
happening from the students kind of
trying to help me in front fix oh you
you just had the order of the bits
reversed or something like that
why don't we try that and then we tried
that and lo and behold it passed the
test and so I think that is that makes
it much more real right you see that
other people also make mistakes and you
see also the other steer students
themselves they kind of it makes a more
much more level playing field other than
that we didn't make an act like an
attempt to put in a lot of active
learning in it but it's a great
suggestion for the future yeah what's
the other question so like I teach this
to physicists and I use a lot of like
pictures and visualizations I got
playing with the Bloch sphere or those
you mean visualizations at the level of
slides or tools that allow you to say
rotate stuff in a we did we did debate
whether we should go down that route
like for instance introducing the Bloch
sphere as a prominent object which is
bread and butter in many other courses
we tried to de-emphasize that because we
thought that's a very physics in notion
but they were certain other like visual
elements that that were they elected for
instance the circuits themselves I think
it's really hard to teach it without
that notion of the circuit
even though once you start programming
you really don't want to think so much
about a circuit because it's not
scalable but the notion of a circuit we
also debated and we decided to keep it
in the in the class we didn't have a lot
of programmatic support for circuit
visualizations are kind of that good
tools for that but we did not really use
a lot of them it was mainly happening at
the level of slides thank you for the
question
more questions so this cars gonna be
offered again next year University of
Washington or was this a one-shot deal
to create it and then we academia yeah
that was the intent yeah the intent was
to create this material so that the
community would adopt it educators would
adopt it and it's just useful to to
bring to bring forward that new
workforce
there were several independent spin-off
developments there is for instance in an
online course where called brilliant
they decided to develop a curriculum
independent completely independent but
they were at some point there was a
convergence of ideas and we helped that
course by bringing some of the Q sharp
elements into the course so those things
were mutually beneficial at some point
the intent was to teach it once if if it
is demand and people want to see it
again of course we can think about
teaching it again I'm sure Krista would
be would be considering it and if as I
mentioned if other professors and
lecturers would like to to pick it up it
would be very nice the word I think
already a few universities who decided
to adopt the curriculum Maria can you
comment it was a university I think in
India and IIT taught it and Mark yeah
okay
a UCLA I was thought it was okay and I'm
I signed up with mark and I'm teaching
it in Ohio awesome this fall great
August and and I'm trying to get
Washington State University I'll be
teaching it there hopefully next be
amazing yeah sounds great
all right good thanks
thank you